i like everyone um i'm so excited for
this series um what are you most excited
for people to see in it the amount of
work that's gone into it i mean
selfishly like like the what's unique
about how we're doing it is that every
episode is like its own
movie that that the denseness of the
text can be
a little more faithfully transcribed to
the screen and that you can be immersed
in these worlds and the amount of work
and detail that's gone into it because
of the nature of the format you're going
to be able to really luxuriate it and
get lost in what do you think like fans
of lord of the rings might be surprised
to learn about the actual making of the
rings of power probably the level of
collaboration that's gone into it
because i mean it it makes sense that
the scale of it is huge it makes sense
that the amount of work that's gone into
it has been
tireless um
but there's still
what was surprising to me is that on the
day of filming
there was something a bit
um independent film gorilla style
everyone's standing around
trying to figure out how to milk every
bit of magic out of these scenes
and um that was surprising
i think you'll be able to really tell
because it's what tolkien did well you
he he created these
vast
universes and and creatures and
uh languages but it it at the core of it
it's the battle between good versus evil
and the intricacies of these
relationships and um jd and patrick have
helped us stay true to that i think that
will be surprising i mean the scale of
it is going to be gobsmacking but also
the poignancy of the relationships is
going to be moving and uh
entertaining uh obviously without
spoilers uh which episode is your
favorite and why probably
the first one because it's it's um
[Music]
going to be the first time you meet
gilgalad you know selfishly that that
that it's a
it is the establishing episode naturally
where we're learning the vocabulary the
visual vocabulary of the series
and um
it'll be everyone's just going to have
this nervous release of okay here we go
we're going on this journey it's the
first step
and um
after that
um
like tolkien's books it just cascades
like a snowball do you have a favorite
moment from the lord of the rings movies
i like that time sam sings that song
about gilgalad
[Laughter]
good good answer i like that um
one of the things is that lord of the
rings has been popular for decades
generations what do you think it is
about the material that has resonated
with so many people for so long the
quintessential conflict between
good and evil
it's something that i feel like tolkien
understood the inevitable rise of evil
and the constant
vigilance that is required to protect
peace
um
[Music]
that there's never a moment of rest
and
that's where progress exists
in the friction between the two uh which
of your friends and family freaked out
the most when you were cast
wife was pretty excited
i mean
she's she's um
yeah she's over the moon
and uh
and also it's nice that i think she's
proud
which is a nice feeling that she's um
you know she's seen the amount of work
that's gone into it
and
for so many people involved it is
required such personal sacrifice whether
it's moving your family around the world
multiple times whether it's being being
apart for long periods of time um
it uh
we're
it's really going to pay off and um
she's been nothing but encouraging i
don't think a lot of people realize
what what it really takes to pull
something of this scale and scope off
how many months of filming the hours
what really goes on behind the scenes
you know
my first day on set
there was something like 200 300 000
hand painted gold leaves on the ground i
mean individually painted you know like
leaves you know unique little
constellations of life that someone has
researched
and
tested and had multiple iterations and
meetings about the color of the leaf the
size of the leaf uh the health of the
tree that the leaf fell from the the
ground that the leaf landed on and now
here i am walking on the set and they're
perfectly placed and the place is alive
with the love and detail and effort that
has gone into it
um
[Music]
that that
that's the amount of care that tolkien
took in his writings
it's
um humbling but also the bare minimum
that it be how we approach making this
hearing uh my last thing for you uh jay
baon uh directed the first two episodes
uh can you talk a little bit about
collaborating with him and like what he
brought to the series that you loved a
bravery and an endless amount of energy
the man can just ping pong all over the
place um and
he is an inspiration in that sense that
he's constantly looking to be surprised
by the visual aspect of it by a
performance and he also does a thing
that i've never had a director do he
plays music constantly and i don't mean
like his ipod shuffle i mean like he's
got a specific
song that will play in between setups or
in between takes
and
it's usually a film score
but what it does is
on a deeply subconscious level it kind
of re
unifies the work that's going on
everyone can kind of get an idea of how
he's imagining the scene going
and even in the downtime when you're not
shooting you're still kind of in that
reality and it's because he's playing
this music
um i loved that
because often times you know you go to
the craft service table you're having a
cookie you know
the kind of air goes out
um and he didn't allow that and that's
something i'll
take with me
on every job
uh from here on out on that note i need
to rap i'm just going to say congrats on
being part of the series cannot wait to
watch all eight episodes thanks man good
to see you again